this is a production of Cornell
University thank you thank you very much
for the introduction and also thanks a
lot for hosting me uh during this uh
semester and I'm really can you hear me
in the back yeah if you cannot hear me
if I'm losing my vot just you know raise
your hand wait me um I'm I'm really
excited about uh this presentation
because will allow me to share with you
some of the research uh that I've been
doing for the last 10 12 years or so
okay so I will be probably jumping from
one topic to the next one highlighting
some results um and sort of closing over
the methods if you want me to go into
more details on the things that we did
and the results just let me know and I
will be more than happy to meet with you
after this presentation now when I said
uh re research that I've been doing uh
for the last 10 or 12 years actually I'm
saying research that was done by my
great grad students and post talks and
also in collaboration with many
colleagues here at Montana State
University and all of us we need to
thank the many many many undergrads uh
that help us every day so I think it
good uh place to start this presentation
is by looking at this paper that was
published a few years ago um and
basically what they did is they
summarized 89 studies that uh basically
came from almost, 1500 individual case
studies uh where they have uh checked
the landscape complexity around those
1500 uh places and uh check the um
abundance and diversity of beneficial
organisms they focus on pollinators and
natural enemies and they check the um
functioning and the services they obtain
from those ecosystems and and sure
enough um as you see here as you
increase the abundance of both uh
pollinators or natural enemies they saw
an increase in the pollination or the
past management
and then one other thing they did is
through a couple of path analysis they
assessed the relationship between the
landscape complexity those beneficial
organisms and the services in that
particular case was yield and of course
as we um decrease the landscape uh
complexity of the system as we simplify
the system we see a negative impact
on the abundance and diversity of those
beneficial organisms and uh the relation
positive relationship between those
beneficial organisms and yield now one
thing that I uh notice from these
studies and you probably noed as well is
that the great although they came from
around the world the great majority of
them came from Europe and from here the
Northeast part of the United States now
I come from Montana uh which is part of
the uh great plain region and that's uh
probably one of the leading uh regions
in the world in production of uh small
grains uh wheat barley pools crops and
forage crops and old seed crops and
however there were no studies uh that
were conducted there so if you've been
in Montana um outside bosan Yellowstone
Big Sky you know the touristic area you
probably know that it looks more or less
something like this I think it's one of
the most simplified systems that can
imagine um because we have across the
state it varies but we have regions uh
where precipitation can be around um 9
to 11 Ines of precipitation per year a
farmers like to leave 50% of their land
in follow to basically accumulate
moisture however in the last 20 years or
so there been quite a big push towards
diversifying the cropping systems and
including pool crops All Seal crops but
still that's the landscape that dominate
uh these systems and when I arrived to
Montana in 2004 I quickly learned that
teich is not really a good option there
here uh because if we have three month
without rains and uh 90 95 degrees and
really strong winds you will lose the
soil due to erosion so a farmers uh
basically have a known till follows
which means repeated applications of
glyphosate and during the crop year um
it's a little bit more complex we can
say they have a series of herbicides
they can choose from depending on which
species they have uh however they come
from two families group one and group
two Acca and ALS Inhibitors
herbines so when I learned about this I
sort of thought this was the most boring
place to do research I thought there was
nothing nothing to really of motivate
myself it was like like I'm sitting here
in
this really simple system except that if
you look carefully you really notice
that ecosystems are not equal there are
differences in the ecosystems and we
start working with um my uh first grad
student F Pak in assessing the community
we communities um in organic and
conventional systems much to my surprise
um no study have even working with
communities in that
region and uh sure enough sort of a
similar to what has been found uh in
other places um in organic systems you
have a different community of weeds um
more diverse more
abundance so the next question um we
asked was so what could this be having
an impact on those on beneficial
organism
and we work on parasitoids as well as
pollinators but for the next 10 or 15
minutes I will be talking about
pollinators now you may be asking me
what why do we care about pollinators in
a system that is dominated by wheat and
phow right well the reason is like I
said there's a huge interest in
diversifying this cropping system
there's a lot of of course ergonomic
benefits for that but also there's a lot
of money I mean lentil uh Montana is the
number one uh producer of organic uh
lenal so there's a lot of money come
with these crops and we also have many
Native species that require uh
pollinators now um assessing pollinators
in this really extremely large field was
a was a challenging task and I was very
lucky uh to be able to recruit uh
subari uh who was my uh PhD student then
stay as a post dog he's now in the
University of Idaho and he wanted to um
check the abundance and diversity of
pollinators he focus on be in this
system and again to the best of my my
knowledge no study has addressed
pollination pollinators across in these
AG Ultra systems across the whole
Northern Great plain region we couldn't
find any
information so what subot did is uh he
went to the north part north central
part of Montana what it's called the
Golden Triangle where the uh with
production is concentrated and for three
years he selected three organic and
three conventional
fields
and to show you how uh simplify these
Landscapes are uh he basically
Quantified the different systems or or
ecosystem they have in radius of 250 up
to 2 kilometers and if you move 2
kilometers from the fields you still
have close to 80% of crop Fields there's
really nothing except wheat or crops
basically and barley organic farmers
tend to have more more Diversified
rotation
so his
um
hypothesis was that if you have um more
abundance and diversity of forms in the
organic uh systems then uh you should
have healthier pollinators and that
could be assessed at the um individual
level and at the colony
level and that's what it saying so you
will have larger individuals and more
successful colonies in the organic
versus the conventional
Fields so what subot did is in each one
of these fields at least 250 Metter from
any border so in the middle of a crop
Fields he established
transects where he put five of these
bumblebees colonies uh we waigh the
colonies before um putting them in the
field we left them there for two month
and a half and
then we uh retrieve them and desect the
colonies back in the
lab he then check for the health of the
individual be by checking the lipid
content the idea is that the Beast don't
fly a lot they won't be investing much
energy in flying and therefore they will
be able to accumulate more lipids but
also if they fly less they're WI will be
more intact so he also checked for the
how intact were the wing
markings and he also check for the
pollen uh that were found in the bodies
of those bees they idea that because he
also sampled the
vegetation he then could be able to more
or less infer where those bees were
foraging from
okay and then he dissected the colonies
and check for the number of reprodu self
and the number of cells with Nectars and
also the number of males and
workers so um one of the uh first result
in terms of the pollen coming from the
bees um he noticed that there were no
difference between this is just one year
and the next year uh there were no
differences in the pollen that was
collected from B coming from the organic
and conventional fields that is sort of
suggesting that they're actually flying
all around the landscape and the most
abundant po came from alala okay so
again suggesting that they fly find the
alala and then they may by come back to
the uh
colonies and probably because of that um
there's more weeds in the organic
fields and there was a lot of volun as
well um those bees have um individual in
bees were able to accumulate more lipids
in their bodies and their wings uh or
more intact so again that's telling us
that they have their food oh suggesting
that the food uh of the sources for
pollen and nectar are closer to the
colonies than in the conventional Fields
they have to fly you know a couple of
kilometers to find those
plants then uh when he look at the uh
relative growth uh growth rate of the
colony it was larger uh in the organic
Fields versus the conventional fields
and when he look at the number of
reproductive cells as well as cells with
a nectar he found more cells in the
organic fields on be on on colonies that
came from organic Fields than the
conventional
fields and overall the was a positive
relationship uh between the flower
density or the species richness and the
growth rate for both years that he
conducted this
study and the number of reproductive
cells as well as the number of uh nectar
uh
cells so the next step he did was to
sayess what is a relationship I mean so
we have healthier individuals was that
this translate into healthier
communities of
peace and his idea was that again less
Poland sources in the or in the
conventional Fields should translate in
uh less abundant less diverse uh big
communities and because of that the
networks uh between flowers and
pollinators should be weaker in the uh
conventional Fields versus the organic
Fields so uh one of the things he did
was to establish these pollen traps so
he was trapping pollinators in all these
fields you can see this is a pretty Wy
field that's one of the organic fields
and
then again he assessed the Forbes
abundance and richness and he spent
hours and hours just walking in along
transect and then checking if one
individual be will land on the flower
and iing the bee and the
flower and uh one of the things that uh
he found is that there were no
differences in the communities of uh
bees between organic and conventional
Fields again shows it suggests that they
are all flying around the landscape what
he saw was a uh a shift in big
communities within the growing season
but no difference across the systems but
the difference difference came in the
networks when he look at the uh number
of times uh a bee landed on a flower in
a conventional field there are very few
flowers and the only he only found three
species and uh six pollinators okay and
that was
significantly uh weaker that the network
that he observed in the conventional
Fields um now remember that I said that
the most abundant pollen You observe in
the Bumble Beast was Alfalfa and it
happened that Alfalfa is the main source
of a uh or the main place where the
those pce landed in the convention field
we can think that the farmer will be
successful in killing all the volunteer
Alfalfa and if that happens then if he
gets R of the alala and if we think of a
landscape where there's no organic
Fields basically 80% of the pollinators
will
disappear however in the organic system
if for whatever reason we don't have
more volunteer Al Alpha which is going
to be a little bit more difficult
because Farmers you know organ IC
Farmers don't have access to those
selective herbicides um still every
single pollinator will be able to find a
source of poen nectar in another
species so in
summary what subot was uh seeing is that
the enhanced fluid resources uh That You
observe in our organic system
um correlates with an increase in the
individual and a colony colony success
and also we have more stable pollinator
flower networks in the organic system
versus the conventional
system so we start thinking well is that
the idea again that if you lose the
alala you lose the pollinators is that
saying that the organic systems are more
resilient than the conventional systems
and you know there's there's many many
many ways by which you can assess
resiliency in a system I'm going to just
show you one of the things that we did
okay and basically this was done at this
side um which is located I think four
miles uh out of bman um basically what
we had there uh is a fiveyear rotation
first we started with safflower inter
with Clover that stayed for the next
year as a cover crop then winter wheat
lentil and winter wheat and we have
three reps each crop present every year
and um basically we farm this rotation
following three
systems first one was the conventional
non-ti system and that system was
basically uh dependent on the use of a
fertilizer and fungicide we don't use
any
insecticides we didn't need to use an
insecticides there and
herbicides now you know the repeated use
of
herbicides uh results in the selection
of herbici resistant biotypes and uh we
have a currently um six biotypes I think
I'm missing one no seven biotypes of uh
of seven species that have been that
have biotypes which are resistant to
different herbicides um three of those
species um I've shown multiple herbici
resistance for example the case of wild
do um a vena fatwa um we have some
biotypes that have multiple herbicide
resistant and is resistant to basically
any incop herbicide so farmers have no
more herbicide to manage without if they
get that type type of resistance the
other uh kind of case of concern is kosa
uh because it has multiple herbicide
resistant but also has resistant to
glyphosate so again a big big challenge
to be
managed so uh the other um system we had
was an organic um non till system so in
this system basically we were
terminating the cover crop and managing
the weeds uh by using
tillage now like I said um there are
areas in Montana where we have around 9
to 11 inches of
precipitation um couple of months
Without Rain strong wings and if you use
a lot of uh tillage uh the main problem
is Sol oan so remember this photo I will
come back uh in a second so the the
third system that we
um thought as an alternative was an
organic system um where we reduce the
tillage by incorporating grazing and we
basically uh use sheep to terminate the
cover crops and manage the weeds um
before seeding and post
Harvest now as I said we are we did a
lot of studies there we assess yields
and pathogens and gr beetles and um
greenhouse gas emission Etc but um I
want to concentrate on this idea of
resiliency today so we wanted to stress
these systems and if we want to stress
the system clamy change is the place to
to start thinking and definitely it is a
major problem in Montana and these are
the prediction for climate change um
under the scenario the worst case
scenario of the IPC CC and basically uh
what they did is they divided Montana in
seven regions and for the 12 month of
the year the prediction is that we are
going to have we are already having
warmer and drier month the whole year is
getting warmer and
drier the prediction for moistures a
little more easy it's not that easy to
make those predictions um however um the
prediction is that we're going to get
more moisture
in the winter and spring and the fall
unfortunately it's going to be mostly in
the form of rainfall not snow so we're
not going to be able to accumulate so
much of a snow pack that we need for
then uh growing the crops during the
summer and the major problem is that the
prediction um suggest that during the uh
growing season June July and August is
going to be actually drier so you have
warmer and drier Summers it's going to
to be more evaporation
challenges so to simulate these uh
scenarios basically uh we have these
systems uh one is what we call the an
open top chamber um where we um were
able to increase temperatures by around
1 and a half to two Celsius uh and then
on the top of those open tote Chambers
uh we included these rain out shelters
uh where we further decrease moisture by
around 40% or so so we measure um soil
temperature and so moisture during the
summer and another thing that we did was
to assess uh plant responses to these
different three systems and three
climate scenarios
right and
um sort of a little bit to my surprise
um
climate the temperature moisture was uh
significant but it has a very slight
impact on those uh we plant communities
with communities a cropping system was
the most important variable as you can
see here this is the teal organic system
the grace organic system and the
conventional
system now something that really
surprised me is that I mean from
previous studies we know that the
conventional and organic systems are
different right we sort of already know
this difference here but seeing the
grace organic system more similar to the
conventional system versus the uh seal
system was sort of a surprise and uh we
can think that in terms of the community
assembly of those weeds that is
basically saying that um heing
seems to be the driving factors here
when you reduce
tillage the amount of till in theg gra
organic system now became to be more
similar to the conventional system that
is nonn till than the till organic
system so teage appears to be more
important as a filtering variable than
herbicides that's a hypothesis that you
may want to test uh later um another
thing that we did was to assess the
impact of these different systems and um
um and uh moisture and temperature
conditions on yield and this is winter
wheat so early spring coming out of
winter uh when they have a lot of
moisture and it's warmer in the H
condition those spring wheat was doing
really good in comparison with the iment
and the hotter and drier conditions
however um when we harvest the wheat it
was very clear that the H was already
getting nail but the warmer and drier it
just basically couldn't not do
it and indeed uh the relationship
between with yield and in this case is
chras uh brost tectorum sort of the
number one uh grassy weed in Winter weed
uh is of course this nonlinear negative
relationship but it was more pronounced
in the warmer and drier conditions so to
summarize uh we are seeing um a shift in
above ground plant communities mostly
due to management systems and also with
some effect on the climate scenario
but we know that the health of the
system and the resiliency of the system
it is on the so characteristics so we
wanted to check the below ground uh
biodiversity and that's when I was
really likey because I was able to work
with Sue ISAC um who's now in
Maine and what she did is she uh
sample the different crops and uh and
management M scenarios but again I'm
going to concentrate on the WID uh
scenario and what you what we notice
here is that the uh evenness and the
abundance of taxonomic units um kind of
uh interact with the different uh
cropping system the non teal the organic
Grace and the organic teal system there
was basically the results were all
across the board it was hard to see any
trend TR um except that in the um
organic gray system and the convention
and non till system we saw kind of a
delay in the peak of the abundance of
those taxonomic unit so again um the
organic gray system was more similar to
the
conventional system non till system that
do the organic te
system we weren't expecting that
result uh another thing that we notice
is that as we increase Sal temperature
there was a decrease in the uh abundance
of those taxonomic units um I think we
were able to find 11 taxonomic units
that associated with the current
environmental conditions 17 with the
warmer and 14 with warmer and drier
conditions and as
we experimentally decrease moisture uh
we also saw a decrease in the number of
taxonomic
units
so one question we ask is could that be
happening would that be impacting the
behavior of the system and the
resiliency of the
system so to answer that question uh we
conducted a greenhouse
study and basically what we did we went
to each one of these uh three systems
and these three climate scenarios and we
collected soil and we basically have a
soul in Noom uh which is basically 4% of
the total biomass that we put in pot so
we have steam sterilized Sals in Steam
sterilized pots and which just added 4%
in volume like a teaspoon of that
soil so we sort of inoculated uh the so
uh the the pot with so coming from each
one of the three systems and each one of
the three different climate anden areas
and we have our controls so we have
wheat in the field we grew wheat and
then uh yep we harvest the wheat and we
grew weat again so we have wheat over
wheat over wheat that's our conditioning
and then we have our response phase and
for the response phase uh we grew either
wheat or a phenetically different
distant species in this case we use p
and why we and the way we analyzed this
was by calculating the soul feedbacks
and basically the soul feedback is the
natural log of the biomass when it is
inoculated
divided the um biomass when it's not
so above zero means that the plants with
the inoculation that inoculum enhances
the growth of the plant and below zero
means that it inhibit the growth of the
plant so in a way it's an assessment on
the impact of those own microbial
communities on the growth of the plants
so
what we decided to use this phenetically
different species because um the couple
of years before that study with Zak
Miller uh we conducted a study where we
have 11 um conditioning SP species we
grab soil from prairies and and crop
fields and we have 11 conditioning
species we grow them for several
generation and then we grew a four
different response species and with we
try to see if we could predict the soul
feedback based on the philogenetic
distance and what we notice is that as
you increase the phenetic distance the
feedbacks tend to go from more negative
to more
positive why is that well uh if you grow
whe over wheat over wheat we know uh we
are going to be increasing pathogenic
organ microorganisms and you're going to
have these negative feedbacks but if you
rotate your crops that's I mean that's a
base of crop rotation basically to plant
something different you don't want to
grow whe and barley we barley that's not
a real rotation okay so again we have
three system three climate conditions uh
wheat over wheat over wheat and when we
planted wheat uh we because it's the
same species
phenetically uh we expected to see an
increase in pathogenic
microorganisms um and therefore we
expected to see more negative feedback
and the say the less negative feedback
will be that the system is more
resistant to the accumulation of those
pathogens okay
so if it doesn't accumulate those
pathogen that fast then it will be more
resistant to that pathogenic Community
or the development of a pathogenic
community in the
soil when we grw a phenetically
different species P we expected to now
uh see
basically potential decrease in those
pathogenic
microorganisms and we expected to
see either less negative feedback or
even positive feedback and the faster
they can recover we can think that's an
estim of the resiliency of the
system
okay so again I'm going to present the
soul feedback Center on zero means no
impact for the three systems non Grace
and till organic um above zero good
there's promotion of growth below zero
there's um s
inhibition and what we notice is that
when we grow weight over weight over
weight
um in the non- conventional and the
grace organic system again those two
systems uh kind of behave
similarly and they have a negative
feedback and we
saw more positive or less negative
feedback close to zero um in the case of
the teal organic system so we can say
that the te organic system is more
resistant probably because you are
mixing the so quite a lot you don't
allow that accumulation of pathogenic
microorganism I don't know that's the
case but before you go to Montana and
start talking about tillage
remember it's a very that's not a good
idea okay because you're going to be um
or the chances of losing Soul due to
erosion are very uh High the good news
here is that the three systems under the
current climate conditions um have the
same level of um resiliency so this is
under the current climate condition now
when we look at the predicted climate
conditions that's um warmer and drier
conditions that's we going to show what
we know we notice is that we lost the uh
resistance of the system we didn't
recover and also we lost the resiliency
of the system
so again we are losing uh we shifting
with communities we are hurting crop
yields we are losing the resiliency and
resistance of our crop Fields so in
essence what I wanted to show is that
even this incredibly simplified system
are very complex and in these systems
just a change in the management
practices could enhance the associated
biodiversity in terms of uh having
different community of wheat that will
have a bottom up effect on the
beneficial
organisms and you will have healthier
and more diverse community of
pollinators however
under um predicted climate conditions
unfortunately
uh the scenario is pre dire now the
other good news is that even these
highly simplified systems are that's
what I learned after being almost 20
years in Montana is that even these
extremely simplified systems you can
still have fun and do uh research so I
think we have a few minutes for
questions yeah well let's first of all
thank
faan
let's open it up for
questions it can't be that simple this
oh sorry go ahead hey thanks for a great
talk it's really fun to see all the
agriology in action thank you um going
back to some of the work on pollinators
and weeds and the organic versus
conventional systems um it seems like a
lot of the the negative effect of those
weeds is going to be a reduction in
yield whereas some of that positive
effect would be for pollinators
potentially and some of the nearby
systems there's a little bit of a
spatial mismatch there and I was
wondering if you can talk a little bit
about um how that might affect some of
the the farmer decision making around
weighing these C for benefits that's
that's a great question so the idea was
to see how farmers will perceive the
potential benefits of wheat versus the
cost of yield
one of the thing that I did not show
because I thought I kind of steering
into the story of resistant resiliency
is that
um one of the studies we did um before
the greenhouse study and before the
philogen this study the first thing that
we did with Sue ISAC uh was to go to um
I think it was four pair of organic and
conventional Fields you know kind of a
fence apart and take souls and yes sure
enough we were able to see that um the
microbial communities was affect were
affected by um you know the management
systems and then we did a similar um PL
so feedback study where we saw that the
if you if uh the crop receives an
inoculum um of coming from the organic
system happens that crop we competition
was decreased and that was a sort of a
hypothesis um Rich me Matt you were
there as well what was it the new
hypothesis for can't remember the whole
title of that paper yes research pool
yeah the research pool hypothesis the
idea that actually in those system we
have more Diversified um you correct me
you have more Diversified cropping plant
species um they will be able to forge
they will be uh a different microb
communities Associated and therefore
they will be forging for different pools
and therefore um the crop we competition
is different so in essence what I'm
saying is that if you go to an organic
field and you look at the floor you see
it's Prett wiy and that's something
Bruce Maxwell told me the first time
just look at the crop and you go oh my
God the crop is really good so so those
I think Farmers organic farmers don't
have the options not to uh
not you they can't spray so they have to
live with those weeds but it happened
that it doesn't appear to be as
competitive
so thank
you
har um you said that the future is
pretty dire for weed in Montana at the
very end there what do given your
experience there what would you
recommendations be for Farmers facing
that
situation
um so I think there was a quite a lot of
uh first before right now I'm doing I'm
I'm teaching research but I was doing um
extension for the first 17 years and and
one of the things that I did is was uh
going around Montana I gave what a lot
of talks about climate change and weeds
you know even 12 years ago when it
wasn't really popular press so I think
it's important um to raise the awareness
because if you're not aware and and when
you start showing like hey your
herbicides are not going to be working
because uh the stomata closes Etc so uh
Farmers start to react to those that was
my experience so first will be to raise
awareness second um there is um an
interest some people are saying um we
may need to to move into more winter
wheat versus spring wheat because um you
know that's the reality we we you don't
get hit by those um um really dry
Summers um there's also some interesting
developing um some some uh weat breeders
have been uh breeding some varieties
which are more Dr resistant and trying
to find crop rotations which are also
less demanding in terms of uh moisture
but in Montana it's going to be a huge
problem it is it is a huge huge problem
so there's nothing you can
do
so so the question is if this if you
have oh yes that's a good question the
fun communities yes we did that we have
a CR student um who did that and she
promised me two years ago that she was
going to publish the paper next week
and still waiting so
Y no fortunately
she thank
you yeah Bob excellent presentation
there thanks for sharing it with us I'm
wondering if you can talk a little bit
about meat bow and alternative props
that you could insert into that system
and opportunities for increasing water
use efficiency uh with PE or other crops
i' I've heard stories um maybe from like
Randy Anderson other people about
putting in peas and seeing um a positive
yield response yes so um first the
person to ask uh will be perimeter he's
he's our cropping system specialist and
that's basically to to your question
that's what he's been working quite a
lot trying to find more efficient crop
rotations and that's what I said uh
there is a push uh towards the
diversification of the coping system
build bring po crops there a lot of
money uh organic farmers L lentils but
also um in terms of um uh water use
efficiency and nitrogen uh you know it
brings a a positive impact on on the
system so the I think the um the wi
follow system sort of unfortunately
keeps uh staying around because I'm
going to be using my sociological heart
here forgive me if you're sociologist
but most of the farmers uh tend to be 65
or older maybe and they are like I've
been doing this for my whole life I'm
not trying to change now so it is kind
of a I mean there's a lot of evidence
that um
there's a benefits ergonomic benefits
for raining incorporating these people's
crops but the mentality still we want to
to manage as we did for the last you
know several
Generations the positive effects on that
is that you think it's more of the
um it's hard to understand how you can
get a a an increase in water use
efficiency when you have a crop instead
of a period you know but there are these
other effects
I think it's more in terms of the
overall net benefits economic benefits
net revenues of the farm because you are
uh fixing nitrogen and also you have an
instead of having follow that just cost
money you have um another source of
Revenue so overall what Perry is seeing
is that is not as bad as uh thought but
there is a a a a net benefit and again
I'm talking about the D places in
Montana I'm looking you know North
Central Montana that's why like these
people okay so if you go to uh Northeast
Montana and and probably South uh uh
East Montana where there's definitely
more moisture that's not the issue I'm
talking about the highly simplified
systems one last question go ahead
BR combine two questions here they're
related um so the first part of my
question
I was wondering if that was the same
across all three
systems no yeah no there was there was
like I said in the three systems you you
lost that resistance because the the
organic till system lost that resiliency
was all negative and the three system
that have slightly positive perhaps I
didn't explain correctly slightly
positive feedbacks in the current
climatic conditions where we added the P
they kind of went to have zero or
slightly negative feedback in the warmer
and drier condition so they became less
resilient
so no no but we were um that was yeah
the system was WID over WID over WID or
WID WID P so WID with p is when you
rotate the crop you get that we use that
as a proxy to assess resiliency how fast
the system recover and they they recover
really well in current conditions but
they did not recover at almost at all in
in the future climatic conditions and
and if you keep having we over wi over
WID which is the best the worst uh
management decision it will be bad for
any one of the three
systems
okay
sure um mention the organic
noav I would
imagine
she that it would do better than a
relatively dead
system
simar how how
similar so that that's a good question
so comparing but the organic Grace
versus the conventional non till but in
that system we did not have follow if
you remember we have a fiveyear rotation
was um safflower Clover interceded then
winter whe uh lentils winter wheight so
we didn't have follow but yes um we were
thinking that just the organic matter
that sheep was Distributing will enhance
the system the and I'm kind of a maybe
not I don't know if I'm going to be
answering your question no one asked me
it's like oh so it's organic Grace the
solution and it's like no because
actually we at the fifth year we got to
fourth year and then by the fifth year
we got totally nailed by Canada thisel
The Perennial weight that was probably
I we suspected they were coming out of
the system and we just could not I mean
she will just look at it and go like I'm
that so so um we you know we we were
very enthusiastic for three years and in
terms of the Agronomy of the system we
at least that rotation was not the best
one for perinal which which is the the
major problem the keys of death in
organic systems
well let's
thank this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu